for seven days with the girls and hey
i'm over you yeah like i'm talking like
somewhere where you really really take
yourself out of your current lifestyle
your daily routine and then you can
evaluate and obviously there is no time
on healing healing
probably takes years it's not like you
never get over everything
but healing to a point then you don't
transfer it onto the next relationship
but i don't think you can not transfer
things to another you can
if you take enough time i feel like you
can you can but there's always going to
be things that may trigger you and it's
up to you
i don't i i genuinely think that there's
some things that your partner might do
that will
prompt a random response basically yeah
like you didn't even know that you had
and that's the moment you take a step
back and you're like okay i haven't
dealt with this i'm gonna revisit that
but also take the time and be courteous
enough to inform your partner like hey
listen if you guys haven't had that
conversation
this is what i dealt with please bear
with me
it will not happen again if you see it
does let me know feel comfortable to let
me know
so i really think that healing is
something that can take place also in a
relationship but you have had to have
done the bulk of the work for yourself
do you think that healing needs to have
therapy so there's some tangible result
because it's like if you're just talking
to your friends like they're more likely
to tell you what you want to hear
where a therapist will like sit you down
and tell you about yourself that's their
job
and i'm currently doing therapy right
now and at first i was just like
this is like what white people do like
no literally because no no no literally
this is this is literally my thought
process and even all the people around
me when i finally told them i'm gonna do
therapy they're like were you doing
fairy people that's like white people
stuff it completely changed my life like
completely the first thing i realized
was there's a lot of internal dialogue
that i have going on
in myself and i have an expectation that
the people who are closest to me should
be able to gauge accurately how i feel
because i intuitively am able to
like
know when something is wrong with the
people who are closest to me so i always
felt that there wasn't a balance of
skills let's say so having that
conversation is not just about oh how do
you feel they really untangle the mental
mess that's in your mind and lay
everything straight in front of you to
allow you to deal with it so it's a life
skill that you can take anywhere the
workplace friendships
like so yeah
they start from the beginning someone
said women tend to use words to
grandiose their predicament toxic
healing trauma
i was going to say so when you were
saying that you kind of um
you know this healing thing and going on
vocation vacation etc to my mind from my
experience because i've i've been with
women who are kind of healing
[Laughter]
and it just seems to me that they're
they're waiting for an emotional
stimulus that has you know a greater
impact than their previous guy yeah so
it's true so women want to sleep up no
no one heals and gets with like a really
nice guy who treated their lives she
gets with like a child in thailand and
then she's like oh [ __ ] the last guy
you know i can do better i'm empowered
then she comes back and you know even
the therapy thing i've met a lot of
crazy women who do therapy and most of
the time when they tell me about their
thoughts on what they think in therapy i
just get a lot of feminist rhetoric i
get a lot of like
using these words and this that to kind
of say things are actually quite simple
that is like
why do you expect people to know what
you think though because people well
some women like to be like to present
themselves as complex and deep
and especially when they're on their
healing journey they want to come across
us oh i've done the work i'm now work
i'm very aware of myself
but then their actions don't reflect
what it is that they're saying to me
someone who is healing is someone who i
think like you said amber has actually
taken time out so i'm gonna be really
quick
november or december last year i cut
someone who was completely toxic off not
only did i cut him off i cut 98 of
people off and i'm talking extended
family like no one knew where linda was
people on my social media if they see
this they're like yeah she disappeared
like it's only june that i came back and
even when before that even when men were
approaching me i would tell them point
blank i have gone through something very
like traumatizing i need
a time like to just deal with myself and
you're someone else's son i'm not gonna
put that on to you and
98 of them was like well that's really
honest i respect you for that and some
sort of basic friendship or connection
was maintained not every day but like on
my socials do you know what i mean okay
i can see your facial expressions you're
like what are you talking about but i'm
very like i know what i'm saying okay
but so
cutting off 98 of people you say yeah do
you think do you think that's like
healthy especially it was healthy for me
because i'm a giver so because i'm
constantly someone who i used to have a
thing of
if someone did something i'd be like oh
but how do they feel if i react and pull
myself away from them rather than being
like you know what you did something
wrong i love me enough to take a step
back and cut you off because you're now
no longer entitled to my presence so a
lot of people yeah my presence because i
know what i offer in every friendship in
every relationship in every dynamic so i
had to realize that i need to take back
my energy
and just do me and it was the best thing
that i did
for six months i've never been so
selfish in my life
i think so you healed by being selfish
yes because i'm a selfless person uh-huh
like don't you
that kind of sounds like it would have
the opposite effect because because
you'd go to the next guy and say the
last six months i've been selfish date
me no that's not it because don't ask
i'm telling you i'm telling you how this
sounds to me
what did you do in your six months i did
indoor rock climbing i went swimming i
painted i started a novel i started i
did things for me so it's funny andrew
tate talks about this how women will
talk like they're the men they want to
date so like if we wanted to date a guy
those are things that like we'd want to
hear about and to hear that he'd done
but like the guys don't care about that
i wouldn't bring up unless they asked
okay
but don't you think so for example right
so when i hear about that journey
um you said like the therapist made you
more accountable right that was like my
first therapist so i chose to do that
yeah okay
but surely if you characterize 98 of
your relationships are so toxic that
they're worthy of being cut off at you
know some some short notice
um because you are a giver which in my
mind sounds like
you lack the self-control to adequately
manage healthy boundaries
then
you know i'm not being rude but that
doesn't sound as much
accountability as a very complex way
of
digging yourself up but that's part of
the journey not everyone's going to get
it at that point so it took me two years
and a few more situations to realize
linda you got a poor issue with
boundaries
you are not gonna if someone comes and
tells you you have an issue
or if a girl calls you about the same
issue and you get tired of her telling
you about the same issue you leave her
alone and hopefully if she self if she
is someone who is self reflective
over time
you hope that that person sits with
themself
until they realize their own mess and
realize i need to change couldn't you
just say stop talking about this [ __ ]
but that's for that person i can't speak
for them but i'm talking yeah
i'm talking in relation to myself okay i
thought you were saying like you were
tired of listening no no no no that was
just a random example oh i thought this
was
you seem like you have something else to